We the 26 letters of the Latin alphabet handed down to us from ancient Rome and
fitted all be it in perfectly to our English tongue.
Wait,
not so fast.
That's wrong.
This was the Latin alphabet.
The rest of these were just crafted by some clever old school maters.
Yes,
it's true.
Your gs.
Jay's used W's and wise don't have the ancient pedigree of the rest of your
alphabet,
but what they lack in antiquity,
they more than make up for and scrappiness.
This is their story.
G was the first to emerge.
Long ago.
Greek God made its way to Italy and turned into Latin.
See,
but in the early Latin,
the sea actually stood for this sound and this sound cook.
We're still the one letter you might think could straighten things out here
between [inaudible] good and let us differentiate them.
That valley into k,
well that was going out of fashion,
but see was still hanging on cooling and going along to linguist.
That's sensible.
They could tell you all about how these two Vilar stops actually share most of
their features and they just differ in one little thing.
Voicing,
but to everyday Romans.
That's little constellation.
The difference was confusing and dangerous.
I mean,
does this say he's milking it or does it mean let him beat it up?
Who knows?
I mean,
it's all seize,
all,
seize,
calm down and opened the door because here enters spurious,
carved Delia's Ruga a former slave that ran his own private school 2100 years
ago,
frustrated with this to face,
see and unable to even write his own name.
Clearly the story goes that he tacked on an extra stroke,
creating a new g and forever sitting.
See,
apart from GE and amazing stroke of genius.
Well,
if seek and have a companion,
why can't you?
Well,
the only you around was actually v from older Greek,
oops salon.
More on that in a second.
Greek word stage to fashionable Latin.
Come back a little after the birth of g and educated writers wanting to fancy
way to write this strange Greek you with.
It's very unromantic sound.
So they borrowed oops salon again,
a new salon,
a second hoop salon,
a Greek even in today in English,
Greek words like system still have that new letter,
a letter missing from plain old Latin words.
No tweaking sees and borrowing wise's lightweight compared to what comes next.
The Middle Ages saw the rise of a new letter I with a tail below it.
What was originally a different look,
not a different letter tailed.
I gave medieval European language is a way to set j apart from I and that's
important because if we roll the story back to the Romans,
we see an overburden letter.
I that had to play both roles.
Take the Latin word for young,
just take it that first.
I was a yes sound,
but the last one's the vowel e similar enough,
but linguistically that means I is trying its hardest to be both a vowel e and a
consonant year add in our swishy tail and this is terrified.
Jay comes to the rescue as our consonant leaving I just as a valve.
So you when he's,
but that's not good enough.
There's another confusing letter hiding in that word,
and it's the next one on our change list.
Like I,
the Latin Letter v covers two sounds of vowel oo and a consonant.
What would we'd call w and that's why we like you when he's,
because it has both of them in a row.
Never fear.
We can sort this out.
Just round out the bottom of that v and what do you know?
It's the value Ra.
But this change actually lingered for centuries in older manuscripts.
TheU is still used as a variant,
a v for both VA and Ooh,
eventually after a long sell,
by the end of the 17 hundreds of two are treated as two totally different
letters.
Finally,
we've arrived,
so we have a better way to write you witness,
but listened to old Cicero's pronunciation of that v what he says.
Whoa.
So I glossed over that change when I said that v ended up standing for both of a
and,
Ooh,
but early on that what pronunciation shifted to something pretty close to,
but not exactly like our VI.
So by the time little Henry the eighth was studying his Latin,
that V had long been a Va.
Seriously,
Henry fine.
Yes,
this book is yours.
Have it.
Well,
speaking of Englishman,
when early dramatic languages like old English dressed themselves in the Latin
alphabet,
they asked about their new found garb.
Hey,
where's the letter from?
My was sound and it didn't answer them back since it's an anatomy metaphor,
but dramatic speakers had already learned to get what they want when Rome was
being withholding.
No exception here,
they cobbled together a new letter of their own by taking that vion,
putting it next to a another v.
Don't forget though that v and you were still two peas in a pod at the time.
Each one useful for making an oo sounds meaning you could write this new letter
as a double V or a double you,
but here's where we should jump off the hamster wheel of history because
eventually that German word starts to turn into von its own,
just like the Latin v before it.
Oh,
history really liked to keep your fingers on that replay button,
don't you?
I'd love to go on and compare other alphabets and talk about how or even if each
individual European language adopted these changes or didn't or made decisions
of its own.
Think about how to this day,
the Irish alphabet makes none of these distinctions except c and g,
but this is a good place to wrap up between last time with the uppercase,
lowercase stuff in these modded letters.
I think you can see that,
well,
you might think you're alphabet's been aging and evolving since time immemorial
in some very real ways.
It's not as old as you think.
Okay.